now hamas officials have told sky news
that a ceasefire bringing an end to the
11 days of bombing across the
israel-gaza border could be reached
within
a day or so since the
israeli-palestinian conflict began
228 palestinians and 12
israelis have been killed that includes
we think about
66 children well let's talk to
the israeli ambassador to the uk
zippy october good to see you this
morning ambassador
look hamas claims to be wanting this
ceasefire
claims there are talks underway your
prime minister saying he is determined
to continue the offensive
why is that well you know israel didn't
wanted this conflict to begin with it
was a pure provocation of a radical
jihadi
terror organization hamas that wanted to
shoot
our kids our women our men millions of
israelis spent the last 10 days in
bomb shelters because the whole country
was under attack of over 3 000 rockets
the reason israel wants to make sure
that
those kind of attacks won't be coming
back again and again
so we want to restore quiet we
definitely don't want to be in a war
but we would like not to have a quick
fix we would like to have something that
is sustainable
so our people can get back to normal
life well what is a quick
what is a sustainable solution to this
unless you
you really sort out the the whole border
disputes the land disputes the two-state
solution i mean that's the only
long-term solution isn't it
the only problem is that when people uh
look at the israeli-palestinian conflict
and they miss this ingredient of
radical terrorist organizations that is
that is not interested in any political
solution
such as hamas hamas is recognized by the
british government as a terror
organization
and as you know part of hamas charter is
to deny the right of israel to exist in
any border so it's not really a matter
of what's the political
uh solution they're trying to achieve
they're not trying to achieve political
solutions there are terror organization
uh trying to to work with violence
against civilians
targeting civilians in israel targeting
schools and kindergartens
in israel the only reason we didn't have
hundreds of kids getting killed um
from our side was thanks to the fact
that israel was using
a very good and sophisticated technology
of iron dom as you know
i mean if if this is as as sort of
blatant as you say
with with hamas not wanting anything
other than the destruction of israel
why then are they going into ceasefire
talks and why
you know ultimately there's unless you
wipe hamas out
there's got to be a ceasefire of
submission so you're going to have to
talk to them at some point aren't you
we need to dismantle hamas capabilities
what happened in the last military
operation protective edge was that
israel reached many years of peace and
quiet
on its cities and we would like to have
as i said
a long-term quiet and peace in israel
we wouldn't like to see ourselves coming
back to this
bloodshed in two weeks time because this
is what happens when
you don't have a deep solution when you
don't have a real
work of what the israeli army is doing
is you know we're targeting just the
military
uh targets of hamas we're trying to
fight
the tunnels as you know hamas was
investing months of money
in building these underground tunnels of
terror
and we are trying to distract that but
forgive me we've seen
60 60 plus palestinian children
killed we think 30 to 40 mothers
killed as a result of of this offensive
we've seen
tower blocks being brought down
including tower blocks that the media
were staying i mean not that the media
should be at the forefront of everything
here but
but you know th these were not all
purely military targets were they
well that's the problem when you're
dealing with a terror organization
they're
using um regular civilian facilities
civilian objects
as human shields and they're using the
children and they're using the media
center
as a place where they locate their
headquarters and as you know
we do everything according to
international law and
whenever we target a military target
this is according to what the
international law allows us when we are
fighting to organization using those
facilities
i would like to say something about the
children you know i'm a mother of young
children
israeli children being targeted for the
last 10 days and they couldn't get back
to normal life
so i would like to say every loss of a
child is a tragedy definitely
from both sides but we're doing
everything to protect life
the only reason we get to see these laws
and the prime minister actually
mentioned that yesterday
that 25 of the rockets being fired to
israel
have been misfired and they ended up
with killing
innocent palestinians now look at this
we're speaking about almost 4 000
rockets being fired on israel
so think about almost 1 000 rockets
being fired on the gaza side and they
are killing people so this is hamas to
be blamed
for the fact that those children are
being killed this is hamas that instead
of
investing the international large amount
of money that
gaza is accepting is building terror
tunnels instead of investing it in
schools
and facilities yeah but you're talking
about israel working within
international law the united nations
security council resolution 2334
um says israel i mean i know there the
the causes of this are
very deep and very detailed and i can't
even pretend to to know anywhere near
enough about it
but but 2334 says israel's settlement
activity which is a trigger for some of
this at least
constitutes a flagrant violation of
international law
and has no legal validity well you can't
stick to international law on one front
and ignore it on the other can you
look uh it's so simple to answer this
question because
in gaza there are no settlements zero
settlement since 2005.
israel did a major concession in 2005
doing disengagement uprooting 8 000
israelis from their homes
because we wanted peace to come some
people pretended and said
gaza will be a new singapore for the
middle east and
look what happened there were democratic
election in the palestinian authority
hamas one this cruel terror organization
and look what happened to gaza they
destroyed gaza they decided to keep on
fighting
and shooting and firing rockets on
israel
and this is the problem it has nothing
to do to settlements when israel is
doing
this work of uprooting settlements and
the results are
more fire more terror we need to ask
ourselves is it really
that issue well the truth is of course
not this is not the issue of settlements
in gaza there are no settlements
well if if you want things to to calm
down
if you want you know ultimately the
palestinian
people to reject hamas ultimately
how do you go about it with the amount
of damage you're causing we've had
cameras
on the ground in gaza city and when you
look at the devastation
when you look at the you know the the
infrastructure being wiped out the
electricity the
water supplies all of these issues
it it makes that incredibly difficult
for anyone to live
in gaza doesn't it it makes it that's
going to do nothing more but
but increase hatred of israel
and what it's doing well unfortunately
there is no other way
to dismantle hamas military capabilities
think about it
we are in a situation where a small
country like israel
all its major cities being under attack
3 000 rockets as i mentioned and people
cannot have normal life now
any other country in the world would
have acted like israel and in order to
defend ourselves when we we're fighting
terror organization
you need to make sure that those
capabilities won't
be in action and and the reason we're
doing it and again we're warning the
people
look at those buildings that are falling
they're hamas military targets and we
make sure
no casualties in civilian level will
will uh be the result of those attacks
and israel is doing a lot israel excuse
me that's not true is it i mean there
are civilians
absolutely no it's absolutely true
because we're speaking about massive
buildings that
all its population gets warning from
israel they can leave and are actually
leaving and whenever we get to see
the the the few casualties that there
are it's still because hamas is using
these people as human shield
not protecting them as opposed to israel
is protecting its people doing
everything to protect life
this is the difference this is a
morality issue israel is a moral country
fighting for democratic values when on
the other hand you see those
radicals radicals complete radicals want
to to make the middle east
go back to the middle ages they're not
interested in progress they're not
interested in democratic violence there
is concern about an international
concern about the israeli response being
disproportionate
on the basis that one can presume
you know or the rocket attacks against
israel they say
thousands and thousands of rocket
attacks couldn't live with that
well no but no no no but this isn't
about me is it but but
you don't have sympathy to millions of
people being attacked
it's not about me feeling sympathy or or
not
with all of this but iron dome has
responded
particularly well now that's that's not
an excuse for anything it doesn't
eliminate any of the concern
but then people say is there still a is
it still necessary to decimate gaza
in the way that israel has been doing
iron dome is not a solution to normal
life
because as you know the only reason
people are not getting hurt is because
they keep on having this
un normal life of sitting in bomb
shelters my parents
spend the last 10 days in a bomb shelter
and they live in the center of israel
this is unacceptable
no country in the world would have
accepted the idea that millions of
people
will be sitting in bomb shelters because
of radical terror organization is firing
this is the duty of every democratic
state to protect its people
the people of israel expect their
government to protect them
i'm sure the british government would
have done the same and the american
government would have done the same and
i tell you
our friends in the world say it's
unacceptable the idea
of thousands of rockets being fired on
legitimate uh you know a democratic
country
wants to live in peace it's not
legitimate you you say
other countries would have done the same
including the american government well
president
biden's been on the flop we think four
times now to to prime minister netanyahu
is israel going to start to listen to
because obviously america is a key if
not your key
ally uh you've got to start to listen to
president biden haven't you
america is absolutely a key ally and
they respect so much our rights
for self-defense look at the last 10
days america was protecting us at the
security council
of the un all those um discussions going
on at the
un arena america stand next to israel
stand beside israel and said
israel has the right to protect itself
hamas is committing war crimes and and
this is where we see our best friend in
the world
and we appreciate the fact america
stands beside israel
but they're also saying it now has to
stop so all i'm saying is we we also
we're not interested in a war as i said
we're not interested in ongoing conflict
but we
are now having uh we're sharing with the
americans important intelligence
we're sharing with them our needs in
order to dismantle hamas military
capabilities
and i'm sure it's really a matter of
tactics this is not the big question the
big question the americans completely
agree
this is a radical terror organization
fighting
committing war crimes and we need to do
everything to protect our people
so i believe that israel is doing
everything in its power to protect its
people
ambassador good to see you this morning
thank you thank you very much